you
[Music]
hello to all the viewers we are here
with the first episode of whatsapp prof.
and welcome professor fight it's nice to
have you with us thank you
before we begin may we ask that you open
for us with a word of Prayer certainly
Heavenly Father as we deliberate upon
the great prophetic themes that are
unfolding before our eyes I pray that
you will grant us wisdom in Jesus name
Amen
so this is the first episode that we can
have and hopefully a series of these
that we discuss current events and all
things pertaining to prophecy and we
would just like to make clear to the
viewers that we don't take sides on the
political front this is all just
discussions on what is happening in the
world if we look at the presidential
campaign in America we've got some
interesting candidates and ideologies
can you explain to us a little bit about
these ideologies and I'll they confront
each other well isn't it fascinating
that the whole political atmosphere is
so acrimonious is such a clash of
absolute opposites and actually it's the
first time in history that you have this
in the United States they've always been
these two opposites but they've never
been so far apart as to create this
tremendous chasm between them they've
always been close enough so that when a
change takes place between one party or
the other party the agenda remains the
same the the issues might change a
little bit here and there and the
ideologies and the ideas might be
different but they're not that far apart
but this time it's really serious so
perhaps we should start at looking
political systems in
general if you go back in history then
of course the system that always
prevailed was a monarchy and there you
had one strong man who made all the
decisions well he had some advisors
around him like even the kings in
biblical times they had the Chaldeans
and all these wise men and the
enchanters around them to tell them what
to do and a monarch was the one who
ruled with absolute power
you didn't oppose a monarch because you
could end up without a head
I treason yes and there was no recourse
to a legal system to help you if a
monarch made a decision that was it
and once the monarchy developed also in
the religious sphere like in Israel and
then was carried forward into the
Christian world eventually the monarchs
believed that they ruled by divine right
so they were chosen and they were chosen
by God and therefore there was no
opposition allowed because after all God
had chosen them right so who are you to
oppose the will of God if God would have
wanted you to be king he would have been
king but you're not king so you have to
submit to the choice that God has made
it's almost like we're going full circle
on that today yeah well in in the world
eventually during the French Revolution
then the monarchy was basically
eradicated and you had the democratic
system come into place it's interesting
that it came into power through anarchy
the French Revolution
and the terrible things that happened in
the French Revolution and the ideology
was so far removed from that divine
right origin that they threw everything
out eventually so in the French
Revolution reason took the place of God
so democracy according to the ancient
Greek philosophers is actually the final
step before tyranny that's what they
said
so democracies can develop to a point
where eventually they fall apart and
people then are looking for some form of
stability and normally they look for a
strong man and so we've had a couple of
these events in history where you look
for a strong man and you can go through
history and you will find the strong men
Stalin and Adolf Hitler and Mussolini
and all of these and they also rule with
absolute power almost like a monarch but
they are embroiled in a political system
unlike a monarchy and the Roman Catholic
Church has always favored well at least
the Jesuits have put it on public record
that they're favored system of
government was fascism
now fascism of course has a very bad
connotation these days because you
associated with Nazism and this ultra
authoritarian form of government but
fascism is actually a form of socialism
if you look at Roman Catholic ideology
then they have a social doctrine and the
social doctrine according to them now is
geared towards the poor the poor have to
be uplifted and the poor have to be
supported etc etc and
and the governments in the world that
were Protestant they largely had a
capitalist system so you had capitalism
against socialism now as I say the the
situation in Germany was that Germany
had been virtually obliterated in the
first world war and eventually when it
grew again there was this socialism that
brought them together the social
cohesion and you had the strongman
influence and then you had fascism and
fascism is basically government and
industry in partnership for community so
they have the social aspect it's the
community as a whole that must benefit
and not one here and one there the whole
community the common good yes the common
good basically so that is why they favor
this kind of government without of
course the bad connotations attached to
it so today you have in the United
States two ideologies which were
capitalism and socialism which are now
coming to a clash interesting that the
United States is a democracy but in
actual fact it's not a democracy it's
never was never intended to be a
democracy it's a constitutional republic
Republican and there's a difference in
in democracy the majority decides so now
let's say the majority has some whatever
evil trade that is so prevalent amongst
them that they want to push their agenda
then according to the majority that
would eventually become law right but a
constitution is different in a
constitution you have a set document
with very stringent parameters and
rules as to how the government will be
pursued and the chosen government's only
objective is to defend the Constitution
that's a constitutional republic so it's
actually when you've got a democracy and
a republic in one place it's it s
actually it can't work eventually it
must deteriorate and that is what the
the ancient Greek philosopher said he
said once once it becomes inherently a
democracy eventually it will unravel it
will take over and change the rules of
the Republic exactly then the Republican
angle takes a backseat and the majority
starts taking the front seat and then
you have this clash so that is why you
have this wall basically against certain
aspects of the Constitution well if this
if this paragraph in the Constitution no
longer applies in modern society what
about this one and what about that one
and eventually the whole thing unravels
and then you end up with a free fall
which ends up in anarchy and people
hating each other and eventually
shooting each other and but what do you
need then then you need a strong man
yeah to sort this out so that's why the
Greek philosopher says the final step
just after democracy is tyranny and I
found it fascinating that when Donald
Trump was being elected there was a lot
of talk about this aspect now it's
interesting with Donald Trump that this
idea of divine choice is again coming to
the fore have you noticed that it's
amazing because what is the main air era
area where he got the votes to swing the
whole campaign towards his side was the
evangelicals that's right the
evangelical vote
was his main support base and he has of
course a tremendous team of evangelicals
as advisors so church and state was now
again becoming a problem and Donald
Trump removed many of the Johnson I mean
Johnson amendment many of these issues
that were you know breaking the
religious system but what's also
fascinating is that there are so many
prophets I have a an article here now
this is quite new a California pastor
who prophesied Kayne West's
transformation four years ago predicts
about Donald Trump that he will win the
220 election and we are all as humanity
wired to hear from God both people who
know Jesus and don't know Jesus this is
now Shawn both speaking he's the one
that prophesied that Kanye West would be
converted and would become a great
evangelist so people are very hyped up
about this and this idea is again coming
to the fore that God is speaking
directly to his people now what's
fascinating is whenever all of these
been there are a number of prophets by
the way there were there was a program
just recently with three prominent
prophets all predicting basically the
same thing the great rise of America the
moral values coming back and God will
intervene and bring about this utopian
era and it's interesting that the Bible
speaks about these things when they say
peace peace and when they bring in all
of these things then the Bible says
there will be destruction no I've still
got this in my spirit about the
president today we we we better catch
hands and yeah
and do something about this they're all
predicting that Donald Trump even though
he is not you know the essence of
Christian perfection but that doesn't
matter
chosen by God he's chosen by God and
therefore God will work through him just
as he worked through David he was not
perfect and Moses had murdered someone
and he wasn't perfect but they were
chosen by God and God will further his
agenda and this ideology is now growing
not only in the United States of America
but worldwide and this is fascinating
now parallel to these political
developments you have the religious
developments so recently there was this
great move towards this gathering of the
religious momentum in the sinned and you
told me first it was the call was and
then they migrated or what do you call
it went over and now has become the
saint and now it's become an
international thing and and in the
United States when the health is saying
Kanye West was there and he had all
these performance but it wasn't such a
great thing in Texas that wasn't that
great well it they were quite a few
thousand people but when Kanye West came
on stage people flowed into the stadium
and offed his show or whatever you call
it you as the people exited again awaken
2020 event in Tempe blaring gospel music
causing traffic and preaching to
thousands Kayne joined by his Sunday
service choir performed Jesus walks
before Kanye gave his own message from
there a mass exodus fans who showed up
just for Kanye and following up the
guitarist for corn well he didn't
appreciate everybody leaving I know you
hear me get back here it's a fascinating
that the send didn't stop there in the
United States there there's massive
meeting in South America just recently
yes now on the 8th of February there was
three stadiums felt simultaneously
140,000 people that came and the
president was not invited but he then
came and delivered a speech thanking the
people and telling them that he believes
in Jesus and that Brazil is dedicated to
God and it belongs to God belongs to God
now they call him 'junior both Sonora is
his name is never
they call him the Trump of the other
things of the tropics yeah the Trump of
the tropics and all over the world all
of a sudden we find this shift and even
in England in the United Kingdom you
have Johnson's who like Trump isn't
exactly the end ylim of the Christian
lifestyle but also by divine right who
was chosen it seems and so you have the
Trump of Great Britain and you have the
Trump of South America and you have the
Trump of the United States and the Bible
tells us that the United States will
lead out in bringing the world to the
point where they acknowledge the
authority of what the Bible calls the
Beast well what's interesting is Mike
Pence went to visit the Pope correct so
so interesting at that meeting where the
religious aspects were also discussed
one of the Cardinals said that the
Catholic Church is the upholder of truth
in the world
so if you want to be involved in the
truth button you know my Bible says that
Jesus is that the truth is the way the
truth and the life and that the Bible is
the truth thy Word is truth and
obedience to God's commandments that's
truth Psalms 119 all thy Commandments or
truth thy law is truth so here is an
organization the Roman Catholic system
that has changed God's law number one
that has denied the atonement Jesus
didn't die for you he died but he didn't
die for you they have changed the
mediator ship because Mary is
co-redemptrix and Mediatrix of all
Grace's you have access to God via the
intercession of saints so it's
interesting that the organization that
claims to have the truth denies all
three of the definitions of the truth
because when it comes to the word it's
only in the context of tradition that
the word may be understood so the word
is not the norm the tradition is the
norm so they denied the word they deny
the the soul-saving mediatorial role of
Jesus Christ and I've changed the
commandments so all three definitions of
truth fall by the wayside but this is
the agenda that is being pushed forward
all of these prophets that are now
coming to the fore and prophesying on
all of these issues they are all
claiming to be spirit led that spirit is
the one that determines these things you
know it's interesting in the st. at
Brazil these stadiums most of these
people that were preaching weren't even
using Bibles
it's all in the spirit and Benny Hinn
preaching with his fire and blowing the
Holy Spirit presumably over the crowd
people falling over and receiving the
spirit so that is true it's not Bible
Lent anymore yes said the Protestantism
was always Bible based the word is the
norm now once the spirit starts leading
apart from the Bible then you have no
standard and when I watch these
programmes where these prophets are
talking and the crowd is listening
whenever the Prophet says something that
their ears enjoy they chair and they
clap but the question is not do you ears
enjoy what you are hearing the question
is is it in harmony with the Word of God
I mean the Bible clearly says to the law
and to the testimony if they speak not
according to this word there is no light
in them so we have to be very wary of a
spirit late movement that is not rooted
in biblical truth now when we go back to
these monarchies in the past well the
great example of divine right was louis
xiv the Sun King and was at the height
of France's power and he was the one
that ruled by divine right now the Bible
talks about the kings of the world will
give their power and to the beasts and
all the reformers of course had
identified the beast with the Roman
Catholic system and the Roman Catholic
system has a social doctrine now it's
interesting that in this election Bernie
Sanders is the one that absolutely
embodies the social system
of the Vatican in fact he attended the
course at the Vatican and he agrees with
the Roman Catholic social doctrine which
is embedded in the encyclical rerum
Novarum so where you have the
redistribution of wealth and this
argument of course is now very prominent
yeah now it's interesting that God being
removed from the political system has to
now allow various systems in the world
but I find it fascinating that the
Protestant world had always chosen
capitalism so the Protestant world the
most prosperous nations in the world had
capitalism as their basis and there's a
shift now towards socialism now what is
the ideological difference between the
two capitalism encourages individualism
and it's interesting that Pope Francis
has decried individualism as the bane of
society we are not allowed to be
individualistic we should only fall into
line with the common good which is of
course determined by the church what the
common good is climate change and course
is one of the great things for common
good so you have this dynamic within the
political system so Donald Trump stands
for this individualism and capitalism
but then the argument is then you have
the super rich and the super poor now
they've been some interesting TED talks
on that period of light with some of
these billionaires talking about this
issue and they say you know what
we cannot greatly contribute to the
economy the one man said when I got to a
store to buy trousers I will buy two I
have enough money to buy a million pair
of trousers but what am I gonna do with
them I'm ready
where to so if I were in the trouser
industry I would contribute for the
purchase of two pairs of trousers I mean
what's that gonna do to the economy but
if I can empower people by raising the
standard of living so that everybody can
afford two pairs of trousers then my
industry would would of course gain so
it is in to the benefit of the
capitalist to empower people because the
more people that can buy the bed of the
economy whereas the socialist thinking
is you have to raise the standard of the
poor therefore you have to take from the
rich to give to the poor now the Vatican
has quite plainly said yes they want to
redistribute wealth now but that won't
necessarily improve the standard of
living of those that are being raised it
will just equal everybody it will make
the rich poor but and what's the right
way to say so again you have the same
system so very interesting to me and I'm
I'm watching it and I'm fascinated to
see who's going to win it doesn't really
matter because if it's the Bernie
Sanders ideology it's the Roman Catholic
ideology if it is the divine right and
the church and the state coming together
on the other side then it's also the
Roman Catholic ideology of building the
kingdom of God on earth so you have this
this kingdom theology and if you go to
for example the prayer breakfast oh yes
that what which was recently which you
have on Netflix yearly on it the family
the family this whole idea of being
there by divine right and ruling by
divine right this is becoming very
prominent in politics what's also
interesting of course is that in actual
fact they are actually king
because if you go into the the
background of the political candidates
then they all have royal blood in them
and this has been the case in the
American election since its inception
all the presidents had royal blood I
remember you did a sermon or a lecture
on that yes the bmobile sustainable
princes correct
so whoever they are doesn't really
matter the fact of the matter is that
the world is currently polarized
morality is seen to have disappeared out
of society and they're trying to get it
back by bringing church and state
together by whatever political system
yeah Democrats Republican it doesn't
really matter so basically we can be
observers thank you very much for coming
through and we hope that the viewers
enjoyed this first episode of what's up
prof. thank you
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click here when the bell
appears click and you will receive
notifications to watch the next one
click yeah thank you again and see you
next time